the temptation when dealing with anxiety
is always and invariably to focus on the
extensible cause of our worry let's say
the journey to the airport or the
forthcoming speech or the letter one's
waiting for or the presentation one has
to hand in but if we proceed more
psychologically we might begin in a very
different place with great kindness and
no disrespect we may step past the
objective content of anxiety and look
instead at something else how the
anxious person feels about themselves
an unexpected cause of high anxiety is
self-hatred people who have grown up not
to like themselves very much at all have
an above average risk of suffering from
extremes of anxiety because if one
doesn't think one is worthy it must
follow that the world is permanently and
imminently at high risk of punishing one
in the way one suspects one actually
deserves it seems to fit that people may
be laughing behind ones back that one
may soon be sacked or disgraced that
one's an appropriate target for bullying
and rejection and that persecution and
worse may be heading towards us if
things seem to be going well this must
just be some deceptively quiet period
before others are about to realize their
error and mete out some horrific
punishment for the self-hating anxiety
is a pre-emptive anticipation of the
pain that one unconsciously feels one is
owed very bad things must and should
happen two very bad people part of the
problem and one of the curious aspects
of the way our minds work is that it
isn't always clear that one is even
suffering from low self-esteem hating
oneself has just become second nature
rather than an issue one has the will to
rebel against all so much as notice to
tease out the sorrow and start to feel
it again as a prelude to treating it
what might need to fire a few questions
at oneself we prepared a self-esteem
questionnaire one broadly speaking I
like myself as I am agree strongly agree
neither agree nor disagree disagree
disagree strongly two people should be
relatively grateful to have me in their
lives agree strongly agree neither agree
nor disagree disagree disagree strongly
three if I didn't know me I'd think I
was okay agree strongly agree neither
agree nor disagree disagree disagree
strongly
growing up I was given the feeling that
I properly deserved to exist agree
strongly agree neither agree nor
disagree disagree disagree strongly if
one finds oneself at the disagreeing end
of many such questions it may be that
one is an agitated person not because
one has more to worry about but because
one likes oneself rather less than
normal and certainly rather less than
one fairly should the cure isn't
therefore to try to dispel anxieties
with logic it is to try to dispel it
with love it is to remind the anxious
person who may be ourselves that we are
not inherently wretched that we have a
right to exist that past neglect wasn't
deserved that we should feel tenderly
towards ourselves and that we need both
metaphorically and probably practically
to a very long hug the logic of this
analysis is truly counterintuitive it
suggests that when panic next descends
one shouldn't spend too long on the
surface causes of the worry and instead
try to address the self-hatred fueling
the agitation anxiety is not always
anxiety sometimes it's just a very well
disguised entrenched and very unfair
habit of disliking who we are our
emotional first aid kit provides a set
of useful selves to some of life's most
challenging psychological situations
including friendship love sex work and
self click the link on screen now to
find out more